reports of a multi-million dollar payout
to Bill O'Reilly have generated outrage
from women's groups and lawyers for his
accusers the former Fox News host will
reportedly receive 25 million dollars
that's the equivalent of his annual pay
after being forced out in a sexual
harassment scandal the National
Organization for Women said in a
statement this 25 million dollars for a
sexual predator is obscene and Warner's
outside Fox News headquarters and a good
morning good morning was you say the
reported large payments of Bill O'Reilly
is angry some of those lawyers who have
women who have alleged sexual harassment
against O'Reilly and his former Fox News
boss Roger Ailes they say in many cases
it's the women who report misconduct who
are who come forward who get punished
not those who commit misconduct Tippie
today we've been very successful here at
the factory even though he's lost his
prime hosting job at Fox News Bill
O'Reilly may still be in line to get an
estimated 25 million dollar payout a
former Fox News chairman Roger Ailes who
was forced out in July was reported to
have left with an even bigger some 40
million between those payments and the
sexual harassment settlements the New
York Times reports 21st Century Fox has
paid out more than 85 million dollars
three quarters of it about 65 million is
believed to be going to O'Reilly an ale
severance packages attorney Jud Burstein
it's disgraceful but it's indicative of
what's going on there were stains client
former Fox host andrea tantaros is suing
roger ailes this is real we have Roger
Ailes getting a 40 million dollar reward
and Bill O'Reilly apparently receiving
25 million dollars it's just astounding
that they would do that and then offer
her a million dollars to settle lawyer
Nancy Erica Smith represents gretchen
carlson I'm not for my take the former
host of Fox & Friends was the first of
Roger Ailes alleged victims to come
forward Bill O'Reilly is walking away
with a whole lot of money and much more
than many of the women that he harassed
and many of the women that he harassed
never brought a lawsuit
and we'll never see a dime still Smith
sees progress in the ouster of Bill
O'Reilly and Roger Ailes these are
extremely prominent men and finally they
have had to leave their jobs not just
the victims and that's important bill
o'reilly declined to comment but earlier
this week called the allegations against
him unfounded Roger Ailes has denied
allegations against him in the past
21st Century Fox did not respond to our
request for comment Norah alright Anna
thanks you know it's interesting where
anna has been standing for the past two
days they immediately removed all the
images like he was never there yeah I
can't find his name not a picture of
nothing including the sign that said
Bill O'Reilly cannot be moved I saw that
picture